[Music]
so
in revisionist history like i said it's
one of my favorite podcasts out there
um you open your season with a
discussion of self-driving cars
and you and and this is a little weird
and i don't know if
you know do you need to be checked out
on this where you try to get a
self-driving car
to hit somebody what did you try what
tell me what happened
first of all let me just say bravo
yeah well i
for some reason i stumbled across this
paper by a guy
who said he was like an urban planner
and he writes this brilliant paper where
he says now wait a minute
if all the cars on the road are
self-driving
then that changes the psychological
dynamic between
cars and pedestrians the reason you
don't jaywalk now
or you jaywalk we do j-rock but we
jaywalk pretty sparingly
right the reason everyone doesn't
jaywalk all the time
is that we're really worried that
someone is driving a car is either crazy
and will hit us or distracted and will
hit us
we know we don't joke all the time
because we know that
the human drivers of cars are imperfect
self-driving cars autonomous vehicles
are
they're not absolutely perfect but
they're really close right so this guy
says well
if the fear of an imperfect driver is
removed what do you do if you're a
pedestrian
you jaywalk all the time you could walk
out into the middle of a freeway
but you can blindfold 100 and they will
all stop
they would all stop so i thought this
was such a hilarious
observation so you need to program in
some psychopathy you need some
psychopathy
programmed into that car you guys what
is it
you guys are absolutely right wait
you've jumped ahead of me i'm sorry i'm
sorry
sorry we're getting there yes yes yes
the answer is yes yes
so right now so i go to uh
phoenix where waymo operates google's
waymo
and that is the only place in the
country where you can hail like an uber
you can hail a self-driving car
it'll come pick you up you drive around
so we got ourselves a waymo
and we drove around dinner for a while
and it was it is clear the dr
the driver the the the the algorithm
the ai that's driving weymouth is the
nicest kindest
most patient most long-suffering driver
in the history of drivers
this is a driver who never gets angry
who will never
flip you the bird who will never lean on
the horn who will never
speed up when he should be slowing down
it's a perfect driver so then i said oh
they actually slow down when they're
approaching a yellow
transition between a green and a red
never run
they'll never do anything they're
perfect so i said oh this means that
i can do whatever i want so i got out of
the car we were in
we're in a parking lot of a alamo draft
house in
chandler arizona and i got out and i
started to mess with the waymo
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give it
away but i was like running
next to the waymo and i was trying to
see whether if i behave like
an idiot what would the waymo do
right now i know what i what a driver
would do a human driver if i
did hit me but what about what would
happen if you know
um so it was this great reminder first
of all that
the people who come up with new
technologies
don't always think through all of the
implications
no one thought when they came up with
the idea for autonomous vehicles that
what they were really doing
was liberating pedestrians to do
whatever the hell they wanted
and i realized you know if you if you
make every car in manhattan self-driving
you realize that you'll no car will be
able to make it down the street right
right that's true yeah i mean it'd be
impossible my track club
meets on the lower east side and we're
all we're
competing for space on one little lousy
little track with all of the
walkers and you know whatever if every
car in the road was self-driving we
would get on
the the fdr drive
and do our workouts at rush hour on the
fdr drive and every car would stop
and wait until we were finished right so
it's like
i found this idea so fantastic
it's like amazing it makes it means
the really really really cool thing is
that it means
and the good thing is it means you
you'll be able to ride your bicycle
through any american city without fear
and that means you will always ride your
bicycle
right the only thing that's preventing
us from riding our bicycles everywhere
is that we're
legitimately scared of getting hit and
killed
now i've removed that possibility okay
so all right so just just to be clear
okay um you know when
as they say uh when they invented
american football and people were
cracking their heads open
this is a joke from jerry seinfeld right
people are not a joke it's a
comedic observation of reality cracking
the head zone so rather than say maybe
we shouldn't play this sport they said
let's still play the sport but now wear
a helmet okay
so so maybe you just have to
add extra rules that constrain
pedestrians so that the traffic can
continue
and that's that's a solvable problem
right yeah it's
i thought you're going to say that i
thought you're going to say what you
guys said before right which is
maybe the response is you program the ai
into being crazy just a little bit crazy
you don't know that could be the one
that doesn't stop at the red light yes
yes 95 certainly they're not gonna hit
you
right but that the minute there's five
percent right then you're like
everybody's thinking now everybody's
reconsidering right malcolm let me ask
you something i don't have an answer to
and i've thought deeply about it and
you're
exactly the kind of guy to think about
it and write about it so
right now we lose at least 30 000 people
a year
to traffic deaths that includes
pedestrians i think 35
000 a year so that's 100 a day and
that's been that way for decades
okay you introduce self-driving cars and
that number drops to near zero
but initially it won't be near zero it
might be thousands
okay of deaths and these are deaths from
errors
in the software or the the the
the pattern recognition software thinks
it's a clear road but
there's a truck in the way that's
actually happened it has actually
happened
so how do you convince people
that 2 000 deaths are better than 35 000
deaths if those 2 000 deaths are from
the errors of a machine
built by somebody in detroit
uh it's you're right it requires
some persuasion but i don't think it's
framed properly i don't think it's a
difficult proposition for people
i mean i am 100 in favor of the
autonomous
driving revolution even as i recognize
it creates a strain like a
an interesting world where you can't
actually drive a car in a city anymore
which i'm fine with get rid of them as
far as i'm concerned um
but i do and also i think the transition
you said eventually we'll get to zero i
think we'll get to zero
really quickly because i think these ai
systems
learn really really quickly they're fast
and you know what it has essentially
gone to zero are airplane deaths
it's essentially zero they're
essentially zero yes and if you
i was talking to the the engineers at
google
um who who have created waymo and if you
will tell if you ask them
they'll say you know just in the last
two years
two years waymo has gotten
like so better the the experience of
driving of sitting in the back of a
of a waymo in in arizona
is you can perceive the difference
between now and two years ago oh wow
okay the car is just driving a lot more
the ai is driving it a lot more smoothly
it's it's there are fewer situations
where
it seems to be confused it um
i was stunned driving in the back of
this way more
it's amazing i mean it's and i think
that's the other thing
that once people experience the what it
feels like to be in these vehicles
what you quickly realize is how much
better it is than you are yeah
and you're much less likely i think to
be concerned about the occasional
mistakes they don't consume ethanol
um right or electric yeah
the other thing is the insurance
companies are such uh benefit from this
so much that what they'll be able to do
is put together
and make a fund where you pay people
a lot more if they are harmed either
either in an accident or if they're
killed
we'll run you down like there was the
the initial accident that happened
remember there was a fatality involving
an autonomous vehicle yes
in in arizona in phoenix i think two or
three years ago
and it was because a woman crossed was
jaywalking
and she had a bicycle right and what
happened is the
autonomous vehicle approached and the ai
had a category for a bicycle and a
category
for jaywalker for human jaywalker but no
category for
human and bicycle and it was confused it
never seen this before
and it didn't know what to do and it was
going back and forth between is it a
bicycle is it a human is it a bicycle as
a human
and while it was undergoing this this so
that's ai artificial idiocy
because any human would know that
difference okay it hits the woman
now the point is that only happens once
right
that if your system is set up properly
the next time you have a category for
that and that's what's like building
codes
it's like building codes every code in
there is because something happened
uh that where people died for for
construction and fire
uh so so malcolm now i'm wondering why
there's a warning that not put my cat in
the microwave
somebody did it all right so so i agree
so this would rapidly converge on
something being
completely safe so what about the case
you know the they're these trolley quest
problems right
in in in sort of moral philosophy so
if if if if it goes left it kills one
person if it goes right it kills two
people
but it will have to kill somebody so it
goes left and kills one person
is this the kind of decisions it's gonna
have to make
or or is it gonna be so good it never
has to have a trolley problem
well the it's interesting the trolley
problem
um assumes out the possibility that
trolley can just stop
right so the third the third strategy is
you avoid having to make the decision at
all
by sacrificing the efficiency of the
journey
and what i think ai these are these are
called in
in ai parlance in autonomous driving
parlors these are called corner cases
a corner case is this difficult tricky
to decipher kind of case and my
understanding is that
in most of these care corner cases what
the car does is
it just stops so got it okay
um and i think it's always safer it's
always safer to just stop
right it will always take the it will it
will do what we're reluctant to do as
human drivers
which is to compromise the efficiency of
the journey
the the ai will always do that that's
one of its great advantages by the way
it's never in a hurry
right right somebody should i would
imagine that if somebody figured out
what percentage of fatal accidents
happened because someone is in a hurry
it would be an enormous number they
changed the warnings on signs they say
traffic and you know 20-minute delay
plan
for being late because once you plan for
it then you don't have to rush anymore
because now everyone expects you to be
late i mean it's a psychological
uh dimension of the of the in the the
helpful sign information on the freeways
yeah but so let me ask you malcolm
humans are programming these ai and then
they sort of continue to program
themselves perhaps
so what about the uh the
possibility of bias introduced and let
me just give a fast example
you you surely read the news articles in
the last year or so
where they had racist sinks
at airports okay because
so you go to the sink and i always
wondered i put my hand there and i said
i guess it doesn't
work and then a white person comes
behind me and then the water dispenses
once they put their hand on them so it's
checking the reflectivity
of the skin if i have dark skin the
signal does not get back to the sense
it's absorbed so it thinks nobody's
there right so i
always thought it was just sorry black
man that's right
you're gonna have to have dirty hands
dirty hands
so so this so this made the news all
right
so i'm just wondering if i'm a black man
crossing the street at night
is the ai gonna know i'm there or is it
gonna think clear street ahead
keep going and okay now let me add black
man in the street
here's the caveat to that neil are you
malcolm gladwell black are you neil
degrasse tyson black oh your miles davis
black
because guess what one of y'all is dying
you know this is real i always tell my
girlfriend who is
a lot darker than i am she's black i was
like i always tell you
if you you're out she's at a night in
manhattan like i was like you can't wear
black i'm sorry you cannot wear black
don't are you nuts like wear a bright
color for god's sake
and she always looks at me like i'm a
madman but
i i you know anyone who's driven at
night knows
when when if someone now this is not
just black people when
some a person dressed all in black
crosses a street that's badly lit at
night it's a problem it's a problem
right correct
where why do people i my fellow runners
we would run it in at night and you know
on a winter's night in the
uh on the streets and they would be
wearing all black outfits i'm like
you're crazy what are you doing where
are you
i always wear a yellow jacket for a
reason how do i get killed by some car
can't see me right right so these are
humans making that mistake but when your
machine makes the mistake or you don't
know to put in as a programmer to put in
some or if you test it only on white
people
and think that it's good for all humans
then this is a this is a bias even if
the person themselves are if they
themselves are not racist or
or in any way they have it was sort of
an unintended consequences
of only thinking that white people are
who's uh
you know you know what's a great example
of this neil i was listening to
something
on these ai systems and they were
developing an ai system to
to um diagnose um uh dermat
uh um for dermatologists
to um diagnose uh to figure out whether
something on your skin was cancerous or
not
and they went to all this work and i
thought it worked really well and then
they realized that what the
ai was doing was looking for the
presence of a ruler
because in all of the images it was
using to learn from
they were textbook images where there
was a little ruler next to the spotlight
if there's a ruler it's cancerous
clearly oh my goodness
but like but no but that i do think
that's a transition problem
right that's the thing about i totally
it is 100
true that ai systems when you're
starting out
reflect the biases okay we got to kill a
few black people first and then then
we're on cue i guess but you don't but
you know
over time i think it's reasonable to
assume
by the way here i am on a podcast with
neil tyson
and i'm the one defending science
what is going on here what
i i'm like guys no scientists know what
we're doing you know what it is
like these guys are crazy i can't wash
my hands in the airport
if i spend too much time around chuck i
become angry black man it is true
it is true i will do that to you you
have this is this is
[Music]
nuts
[Music]